قال منسق الامم المتحده الخاص لعمليه
السلام في الشرق الاوسط تورين سلاند ان
تبادل الرهائن الاسرائيليين بالسجناء
الفلسطينيين امر ضروري لوصول المساعدات
الانسانيه الى اكثر من مليوني شخص في
غزه لا يمكننا الخروج من مكاننا الا اذا
بدا وقف اطلاق النار هذه اول نقطه وياتي
وقف اطلاق النار هذا نتيجه الاتفاق على
تبادل الرهائن مقابل الاسرى وستكون هذه
الاليه قادره على منحنا الفرصه للدخول الى
مناطق غزه وايصال مساعدات لم نتمكن من
ايصالها حتى الان وفي وقت يستمر فيه
القتال من المستحيل على نظام الامم
المتحده تقديم الخدمات بشكل كاف واكثر
فعاليه على الارض تدور حرب النشطه للغايه
في منطقه رفح حيث يتجمع فيها اكثر من
مليون و2 الف شخص ورفح وكرم ابو سالم نقطه
الدخول الوحيده النشطه للامدادات
الانسانيه واذا اغلقت في لحظه ما سيكون
الامر كارثيا
تماما